khi tích lựa bất sĩ người dựa ăn bị tâm kính quán tập về được vong người đã đi làm chờ lại.
Sao ngay đau mây tăng chính, sau hôm năm tháng bị tay hạt kinh hoàn tệ các tập về giờ có phi hông,
thái hà đống đà ăn nội. Bất sĩ hòn mình liết ở quay trở lại là việc tạc bệnh vệnh gịt gà,
hà nội. Dấu xương tiên sĩ lên lên quán, sáng bốc mình vẹn gà cũng lãng của sạc tổ hợp tân châu,
và các đồng nghiệm chúc mừng lựa sĩ chính thức đi làm chờ lại. Chức đó,
như bất sĩ nội chú hoàn mình liết,
hà mình chính tuổi, với quán tại giễn đồng, giễn châu,
nghe ăn vừa tốt nghiệp bác sĩ nội chú uống thư,
không tắt tại việc gần gà cơ sử tân châu.
Thếp nhận công việc chờ được bao lâu,
một tay nạn không mai đã sẻ ra với bác sĩ li.
Chúng đêm bữa bảo ngày hai môi tháng tư nằm ai ngàn tương trả mai mệt tư,
sau anh hình hình của gió,
hô tâm kính cường lực của quán tập về bị phở đường sập,
đâm bóng người bác sĩ li,
sau nâng tháng đều chủ trải qua nhau lên tốt thật,
lòng lực, tiêu hóa, tận tích niệm chẳng tương của sống
và phục khổ chức năng,
với những lực phi thường cùng sử dưới tận tịch
của đường uống ý vắc sĩ,
sử chiên sài được viên bất kích thư quán đàn thề.
Đột sả cả nước,
mặc sĩ hà mình li đã có tình hợp tốt về sự quay,
đi làm trở lại trong liên vui,
vóng tay chào đón của các lòng viêng.